now every day as much as we can we try
to bring you on these shows the voices
of ordinary Gins let's talk to Zach
hania you're a resident in the alati
refugee camp it's located on the
coastline of Gaza in the north of the
strip uh you're joining me live I see
your I see there's no light uh I'm
assuming this is some device or maybe
your phone for for us to be able to see
you tell us what your situation
is uh hi it's a torch I use and we don't
have any electricity any lights around
uh the whole Camp is is in complete
darkness
now today they dropped a leaflets asking
the beach camp people to go to go to
leave to the
South and in 3 hours and people don't
know where to go some of them they went
to the schools some most of them they
stayed at home and they said we going to
die in our
homes better than be humilated going on
the roads and be killed the road Zack
this is what I was trying to find out
with our correspondent in Gaza City
earlier is it possible when when the
Israeli military at the moment is
telling people to go south is it
actually possible to do that
safely my neighbors I I just was
downstairs on the road and my neighbors
they went to the South and they asked
them to go on the on the road by the Sea
the coastal Road and they shoot at them
they shoot it that they shoot it at them
and they came back and now people going
to the school and the schools are full
and people staying on the floor on the
hall on the front yard of the schools
and around it we don't know what to do I
don't know I just want to to say
something one thing go ahead are you
enjoying are you enjoying this scene
this movie hor of movie is the word
enjoying
this 10,000 people now did and more more
than
10,000 many kids of three and a half
thousand kids I don't know is that
enough to to move the humanity or not
how many more do do we need to like you
know how many people need to to die to
be killed for the people for the world
for the world leaders to move to do
something we ask for a ceas fire we are
all civilians we are staying in our
homes and waiting now we don't know what
is going to happen to to tonight we
hearing the B
outside
now it's nonstop and we are very
frightened the girls the kids are very
fearful and shaking when they hear this
sound tell me about your family who's
with you right now who's with you right
now your
family my my my wife and four kids and
my nieces five of them with their little
kids we have two months baby two months
old baby and I look at them and my heart
break what are your children saying I
don't know how they my blood is boiling
we we need to stop this this is inh
human
uncivilized I don't know what to
say I understand that you have I have my
aunt my my my uncle my uncle's wife
she's my
aunt she's she's in Kaa and we don't
know if if we get if we going to go
anywhere how to carry hair how to do how
to do to manage this how to handle this
she's in coma she's like you know
paralyzed she's she's with you in the
house old old parents old people we
don't know what to do with
them your aunt that you just mentioned
who is paralyzed she's under your care
and with you in the
house yeah next to my house my my my I'm
looking after them my uncle and his wife
they are old and if they bomb now the H
like you know in around the house or in
the house we don't know how to carry
them and how to manage this you know how
to
do I understand
that nationality is that
right S I understand that you have dual
nationality is that
right yeah I am an Irish Citizen and I
am cont in contact with the Irish
empathy and the Department of Foreign
Affairs in Ireland does the rest of your
family also have does the rest of your
family also have dual nationality and if
so would you be able do you think to
leave via
Rafa at the moment we can't we can't go
anywhere if we go to the
South the tanks are on the middle of
Gaza Gaza Strip they will shoot at us we
it's not safe it's very dangerous if we
move anywhere now
when when night time fall we stay in in
our houses because we it's complete
darkness we don't see anything outside
so all people now staying in their homes
and with this warning people are
frightened tonight what is going to
happen tonight for
us please keep an eye on on on on the
beach camp tonight we don't know what's
going to
happen Zach where are you getting food
and water from how are you feeding your
family at the moment
we're struggling every day in the
morning we wake up and we start
searching for
water some some like you know horses
they go around with little water and
people queing for hours to get a little
few liters of
water and it's a struggle and I ask my
boys to stand on the road to to see if
anybody passing by who has water
drinking water or drinking clean
drinking water that's what we need most
every everything in Gaza is in short now
we are in short of everything but
death what do you what the world leaders
need more to move to do something do
they have hearts like like us do they
have conscious or
not this what we are seeing moves that
Stones Zach I want to ask you please we
ask for a ceas fire
I I want to ask you something of a
personal question if I can you said you
have four children you're there with
your family what do you tell your
children tell them about with they if
whatever I tell them I calm them or or
whatever because they hearing they
hearing the the fighter jets on top of
us all the time the drones does not go
anywhere we can't
sleep I I can't last night and today I
couldn't sleep every time I try to sleep
bombs bombs bombs bombs and everybody is
exhausted and tired I try to calm
everybody but I need to somebody to calm
me as well everybody is stressed
everybody is
fearful we don't know what the the next
minute we don't know what is going to
happen look maybe you hear this we're
hearing this all the
time it's bombing around us all the time
all the time and in the camp they
attacked a school today this
morning full of people they attack and
five people
killed and you told us earlier that you
had tried going to a school did I get
that right you tried going to a school
and you told me it was
full yeah my my other my sisters are
there and I asked them he told me it's
full full of people you will be standing
and you will be on the floors on on the
fr the yard on the school yard sleeping
on the in the air in the open air I
prefer to stay in my home and many
people are the same they prefer to be to
stay at home and die in their homes
instead of being
humilated we have dignity we have we
have feelings we are like everybody
else we look at our kids and our hearts
breaks our heart is dead we are dead
inside we speak we are alive we move but
we are dead what we are seeing around
us Zach I hear you I ask the world
government to move if they are humans if
they are humans if they have any any
feelings if they have any
conscience to stop this this is not fair
this is a criminal genocide in front of
everybody life you see this
life it's a it's a
Holocaust in front of everybody's eyes
all right what do you need to stop this
look zank I I I want to thank you for
taking the time um using your torch also
to send that message out to us to our
viewers and taking the time in the
circumstances that you're under right
now you and your family and we of course
you know hope for your continued safety
and uh we will try and check back in
with you We wish all the very best to
you and your family
Zach thank you thank you thank you